good morning and welcome back to day
three of PAX East 2019 I'm Lourdes
sovereign here for the iron Lords
podcast and Lords of gaming dotnet and
we're here at the booth at motion twins
booth looking at dead cells and dead
cells new dlc rise of the giant here we
have a developer to talk to talk to us
about the game morning thanks for
joining us so tell us your name and what
what part you form of the team and a
little bit about the new dlc hi I work
with the motion tween team on all the
communication and marketing matters for
the chimp I also do a bit of game design
and generally I do what all the death
don't want to do all the dirty work all
the dirty work it's on my end it's
really focused on end game contents it's
completely free we promise that a while
ago to the community to give back
because we wouldn't be here without all
the players all the feedback all the
improvement the community bring bring to
us brought to the game so it's three and
game content you have two new levels and
two new bosses alpha with being only
available if you're really good really
really good at the game so only if
you've beaten the other hand of the king
and the King you have to beat the end of
the King like four times so it's very
hard good luck to quickly just for
anybody who may not have played dead
cells and if you haven't played dead
cells play dead cells good night can you
give a little bit of a recap of what the
game is about the type of game that it
is yeah of course well it's it's very
very very much inspired by Castlevania I
would say let's look first
the first idea behind dead cells was to
do Castlevania you could replay a lot
so that's why we did work like
Castlevania with secrets all the way
because in Castlevania once you know
where the secrets are where they will
never change play you know everything so
here the secrets the weapons the enemies
everything changed each time you begin
it around so basically that tells you
you have prisoner in island and your
main goal should be to flee or to
understand what's going on on the island
by the we accuse curves that make
everything go back to life even if you
if you die with that said it's very much
in that can slash action that former
game so in terms of rise of the giant
did you guys had any new mechanics in
terms of gameplay any new sort of
weapons any new abilities no new
abilities because we dead sets also a
weird mix between a rogue Metroidvania
and a roguelike so we do have abilities
allowing you to unlock new part of the
island no new ability in this DLC maybe
more coming later I don't know in terms
of mechanic as I said the goal of this
DLC is to give player that already beat
the game new meat to chew on so and
under high I mean you can beat dead
cells on in the base difficulty mode and
when you get like versus one person's
tumor cell free difficulty verses 4 and
5 with you mechanic each time you play
you you are on a new
difficulty level and now instead of just
adding enemies with more elf and more
damage we also added new maps in this
difficulty and your rewards you never
you never you can't have elsewhere than
miss difficulty so the idea is to give
more incentive to play great so when I
know the DLC is out already for Steam
right correct when is it coming to other
platform I would say between 1 and 2
months you know we we are cleaning the
DLC with the PC version first with the
PC player giving us feedback on the
balancing reporting bugs and tipples
things like that and and then we submit
the whole thing to the consoles we go
for the education process which is about
three weeks and finally we can bring it
to console people so yeah one two months
depending on how fast we can green
lights the TLC so beyond rise of the
Giant you guys are planning more DLC and
are they working on something new at
this point as well I would say both both
like we were obviously planning to keep
updating the game with patches fixes
updates
as long as the community demands as long
as various achievements hormone will
bring more to the game is amazing I know
the community is rapidly demanding more
yeah so so I think we will doing with
that sense for a few years if you feel
good Portuguese but at the same time
part of the team is going to think maybe
even do some work on pre-production for
potential new projects the thing is we
have absolutely no idea of what we are
going to do next so first we want to try
new things if it works test different
possibility well that that's super
exciting because you guys are a small
team right you're very also what you
guys managed to do with that cells is
absolutely amazing achievement so thank
you so much for your time and really
appreciate it guys this is motion twin
this is dead cells and this is their new
dlc rise of the giant look out for it on
steam and in a few months on consoles
thanks